[Musique]
avec moi en plateau et yann malet
bonsoir soir président des amis du musée
de la toile de jouy à jouy en josas la
commune lieu de création au xviiie
siècle de ce célèbre tissu créé par
oberkampf qui jouit encore c'est le cas
de le dire d'une belle réputation
aujourd'hui les créateurs s'en inspire
l'association avec le musée de la toile
de jouy ont lancé en janvier un prix un
prix de la toile de jouy c'est jusqu'au
16 mai le dépôt des candidatures est
fixé jusqu'au 15 mars déjà pourquoi
lancer ce prix quels sont les objectifs
bah écoutez d'abord il ya un engouement
pour la toile de jouer vous venez de le
dire pas seulement d'ailleurs dans notre
région mais au niveau international
c'est connu dans le monde entier et on
s'aperçoit que le plus en plus de gens
nous interroge via nos musées ce que je
recommande vivement à tous les
téléspectateurs de faire parce qu'il ya
des expositions permanentes temporaires
etc et donc face à cette demande très
forte hausse et dhiba au fond pourquoi
pas créer appris la toile de jouer
qu'ils fassent un pont entre l'ancien je
dirais et le moderne et le contemporain
c'est ça l'idée qu'elle a besoin sans
cesse de se réinventer en tout cas
d'avoir de nouveaux talents qui a
signalé comme comme la dalle de jouer
est une est extrêmement riche en thèmes
variés il ya plus de 30000 motifs
différents qui sont sortis de la
manufacture c'est à jouy en josas ou
xviiie siècle jusqu'au 19ème simple
d'ailleurs et donc les thèmes sont
extrêmement variés et continue
d'inspirer des décorateurs d'aujourd'hui
est donc on s'est dit pourquoi pas
lancer un concours sur le thème de la
nature retrouve figurèrent revisité mais
avec une vision actuelle de ses motifs
c'était ça l'idée est donc s'intéresser
donc à des jeunes créateurs étudiants
mais aussi à des professionnels qui son
métier si vous voulez de faire de la
décoration de l'ameublement ou
mode une grande variété vous dites la
toile de jouy été reconnue dès sa
création xviiie siècle aussi pour sa
qualité
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'elle était
prisé par la bourgeoisie par la cour
royale aussi à l'époque absolument
d'ailleurs c'était commode puisque jouy
en josas est tout près de versailles a
fait et donc qu'il y avait à la fois
l'eau puisque c'était la vallée de la
bièvre et la bièvre et puis il y avait
le les clients et c'était la cour de
versailles effectivement qui était très
affriolante est très intéressé par tout
ce qui tournait autour de la toile de
jouy pour pour s'habiller et pour
décorer leur intérieur
alors si on vient au prix qui est lancé
vous l'avez dit les candidats devront
proposer une nature imaginaire c'est ça
le principe oui ils devront faire preuve
d'imagination pour pas forcément faire
une nature imaginaire ça peut être une
nature très réaliste c'est à eux de voir
mais eux si vous voulez de s'inspirer le
motif qu'ils sont anciens mais dont
certains d'ailleurs ont une même si on
les regarde de près on écoute et très
moderne il ya desquels fois les motifs
géométriques par exemple qui ressemblent
à des tableaux tout à fait contemporain
et donc pour ce prix il en fait même
deux prix de catégorie expliquez-nous la
différence alors parce que si vous
voulez il ya d'une part des jeunes
étudiants les lèvres qui sont donc en
cours de scolarité et qu'ils veulent on
les comprend père s'est petit à petit et
que donc ils peuvent à l'occasion de ce
prix puisque l'étoile et leurs oeuvres
seront exposées non seulement d'ôter la
prime est exposé et donc connu ça peut
être pour eux une petite rampe de
lancement pour leur carrière
mais d'autre part il ya le seul la
seconde catégorie qui sont s'adresse
plutôt à des professionnels plus
confirmés et celle là bas c'est
simplement pour cul parce que c'est un
métier si vous voulez qui a besoin
d'être connu reconnu et le prix peut
être une notoriété pour leur travail
comme on y participe à feu on s'inscrit
tout simplement on s'inscrit sur le site
du musée la toile de jouer qui est en
train de s'afficher
et où on suit on suit le mode d'emploi
alors la date limite et fx et je le
disais des candidatures au 15 mars
toutes les infos vous l'avais dit à
retrouver sur le site du musée de la
toile de jouy un mot pour terminer sur
votre association les amis du musée de
la toile de jouy
quel est son rôle est finalement quel
complément avec ce musée qui est située
à jouy en josas
et bien si vous voulez son rôle c'est
d'accompagner le développement de ce
musée donc d'organiser si vous voulez
tout ce qui peut faciliter sa notoriété
son développement ses finances ont fait
appel au mécénat ont fait appel à nos
adhérents et on fait appel on fait des
conférences rôle organise des visites
dans des lieux différents qui ont un peu
des rapports évidemment avec la toile de
jouy
mais dans les musées parisiens ou dans
des musées en province ou un château de
versailles
et tout ça en faveur si vous voulez de
l'association et du musée de manière à
ce qu'ils aient des retombées de
notoriété mais aussi des retombées
financières puisque un musée c'est
toujours un lieu qui a besoin de
finances et donc on s'emploiera ce qui
on l au maximum mais ont finalement ce
prix ça participe aux actions de
l'association faire la promotion de la
toile de absolument merci à étienne
mallet d'être venu en parler en plateau
je rappelle que vous êtes le président
de l'association des amis du musée de la
toile de jouy donc à jouy en josas
toutes les informations sur cette
association a retrouvé sur son site
internet
[Musique]